this thirteen year old girl is safe now
in kaya town more than a hundred
kilometers from her village farther
north it was attacked a few months ago
by unidentified armed men we've hidden
her identity for her safety
she says she still finds it had to
forget those moments when they came
shooting and killed her father
everyone was fleeing they were chasing
others to the hills where they killed
them
some people even tried to climb trees
but they killed them all these children
have fled from their homes after attacks
on villages they find solace through
dance play and just talking to each
other at this Center that is being run
by the UN child agency most of the
children have witnessed Horrors some
lost their relatives and friends we have
different games for them sometimes we
organize a session where they speak out
I think that's when the healing starts
nearly half a million children in
Burkina Faso are out of school this is a
big problem in a country where only
about 60% of students complete primary
school like in many conflicts most of
those who are fleeing are women and
children
the displaced children are now being
placed in government schools in areas
where they fled to or therapeutic
centres where they can play and get
counseling but these facilities are few
crowded and far apart some of the
displaced people have taken refuge in
classrooms but when children resume
classes in October they'll have to leave
in all about a thousand schools have
been closed because of the security
situation this teacher at the primary
school of 400 pupils
says they just stopped coming to class
when you go to school and there are no
students they have all left you also
have to leave there are no students
because their parents have told them not
to come there's a lot of fear in the
villages for now the government and aid
work has just wanted to make sure the
children have the basics a safe place to
leave food and a school to carry on with
their education
but they also know the longer the crisis
persists the higher it will be for the
children to receive a proper education
Catherine saw a al Jazeera northern
bikini facile